hello Frank you can call me the doctor
I'm the one who operated on you and the
reason why is simple you killed my
brother this operations a reminder of
the terrible thing you did I have
liberated you from the macho prison
you've been living in good luck Frank
this is your opportunity our attempt
ssin
[Music]
yeah to me Frank
I need to clear my head Frank look a
little different okay I got high to do
this job
while wanted again
why me the doctor wanted you the guy you
pushed year ago it was a family thing I
wanted to call it Frank Koechlin Mormon
need to speak to the stock
make a lemon wedges one thing she should
change is going to come so trying to
figure you out of the made enough
trouble Venus
I gave you a new champion life you
waited to take them out
there is anything left the Frank kitchen
it was this point-blank aim
kitties Ella Frank you can call me the
doctor this operations your reminder of
the terrible thing you did this is your
opportunity for redemption yeah to me
Frank
Frank look a little different I got
hired to do this job the mob wanted to
get you why me
the doctor wanted I wanted to call it
Frank kitchen in Mormon psychic pain
still trying to figure you out and I
made enough trouble Venus
I gave you a new chance in life
you wasted
there is anything left a friend kitchen
and with this point-blank aim
coming to get you
you
you